racial justice campaigners and
award-winning music artists including
alicia keys and khalid have come
together calling on the
new biden administration to create a
commission
on racial justice in a moment we'll
speak to two of the co-founders of the
breathe with me revolution but first
let's take a look at the latest campaign
video
i can't believe i'm back four years
later with 17
more ways you can be killed leaving a
party
joining edwards sleeping in your home
dominique clayton sitting in a
wheelchair
jeremy mcdonnell riding your bike
ronnelle foster
suffering from a mental illness walter
wallace jr
uh joining us now two of the breathe
with me revolution co-founders er profit
joining us
up from atlanta and lee blake uh in los
angeles for us this morning
great to have you both on um uh leah i
wonder if i might start with you just
just tell us about the genesis of this
project the breathe with me revolution
uh speaking to quite a few people really
yes it's very interesting because as you
can hear i'm british
this began when my dear friend
sia saw the footage of john of george
floyd
and became totally devastated by
it she was there in england she has an
amazing design company
and she called me crying it must have
been about three in the morning for her
and she said you know what on earth are
these
why are these people so hateful she said
you know
we're dying of covered everywhere black
and brown people
and um now they just wanna you know
step on our necks and just kill us even
in spite of this
and she said but however this is the
first time that all my white friends are
calling me
saying this is so terrible so terrible
what can i do
how can i how can i help what can i
finally do
she is tanzanian but um educated in
britain
and lives in britain and i she said um
that she said to her friends you know if
you're not breathing with me
then you're contributing to my demise
and
so i said oh my god sia that is a
campaign
and we came upon breathe with me
revolution
out of that and um i've been friends
with prophet for a very long time
um and we all got together and realized
this is something that we couldn't be
silent
or inert about we've both done
you know i've done decades of
humanitarian work
so this was just a follow-on and a
natural thing for me to do
and um you know it's been very
successful so far i'm thrilled to say
and yes we're calling the rachel healing
commission
well that's we'll just pick up on that
point with profit tell us then a little
bit about about your involvement and all
of this is part of the black music
action coalition but
but specifically this this commission on
truth
at racial healing and transformation now
this is something you want to see
at joe biden of course kamela harris
bringing forward
in the first hundred days profit
one thousand percent um as lee mentioned
earlier i i have been
i've known lee for over 20 years and
always been
a fan of her work and her ability to
corral celebrities around
issues uh that were dying to the
community
uh so um black music action coalition
formed shortly after george floyd
as a response to the music industry's uh
quote-unquote desire
to address uh racial uh disparity um so
for us it was a natural
partnership to connect with lee on this
issue we was a fan
of what was done with 23 ways how
impactful that was
so we knew that 17 more waves would have
the same
level of impact uh so we immediately
began to corral artists around this
issue
and uh we are very happy with the
success thus far
um it's only the circus though uh we
won't stop until we actually get this
commission done
and we just on on the commission itself
of course we've seen
truth and reconciliation committees in a
number of countries around the world
many people will immediately think of
the one of course that was set up in the
aftermath of apartheid
in south africa i i understand the
desire to get some answers to to move
forward
with the process of healing but given
what we have just seen
in that fractious presidential election
campaign
culminating in those in those riots in
the capital itself
is the first hundred days of the joel
biden administration the time to get
started with this or
perhaps should the dust settle slightly
well we think it's been time um
you know this has been going on for 401
years this
immense brutality perpetrated on
black people in this country and talked
to them frankly by
our ancestors um and enslaved here by
our ancestors so um you know it's been
time
and we feel there's no better time than
when the country is
divided for us to all see healing as our
future
and really impress upon
everyone that's calling for racial
equity that we can't have
racial equity without truth we need to
tell the truth about
the incredible ways from slavery onwards
from 1619 onwards that black people in
this country african americans i should
say in this country
um have been brutalized absolutely
completely brutalized and it's
it's just time i mean it's really time
um profit yeah you you're nodding along
there look personally
from my own perspective you might detect
a bit of a scottish accent about me
events over the past couple of years
have forced me to to have a look at
scotland's
own role in the slave trade and the
street names in glasgow for example
it is an issue that we all have to deal
with but what more generally though
profit do you think
is the role of you know people who
aren't of color
in this discussion clearly lee's very
active in all of this
but sometimes there is a feeling people
want to help people want to be allied to
the cause
but kind of don't really know what to do
for fear of you know
offending insulting someone like
yourself
i mean you know i think an individual
would have to figure that that kind of
out for themselves but i think what you
what people can do and particularly
allies is join us in this call for truth
i think what you experience with the
world watched on
on on january 6th uh this insurrection
if you will
was simply a reflection of the deep
racial divide
in this country and until we deal with
it until we actually root this thing
up dig it up uh analyze it and then heal
from it everything else is a band-aid um
all the uh policies that we're fighting
for
all the different reforms that we're
looking to see happen are all great
but um on a null and void if you don't
have the root of this thing
actually dealt with and that's what the
truth commission would do
so um i think all people uh black people
in america
and allies uh people who understand that
uh who watched those eight minutes and
52 seconds of george floyd's murder
who watched uh brianna taylor be
murdered in her home
uh people who have watched decades and
decades and decades
of discrimination against black people
in this country
if we're serious about hell in this
country we're serious about
bringing this nation together and to be
an example of the world a truth
commission is the only way
uh lee blick prophet particularly profit
for staying up
so well both of you for staying up quite
so late really appreciate you joining us
in the program this morning thanks for
being with us
thank you thank you so much